me
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
how are you doing
i'm good
we're doing good
so
today's on
to islam huh
yes
so
fire
you definitely know a little bit more
than i do
right off the rip
um so i think it's best for you start
yes
so first
to all viewers that are here smash that
like button before we go in quick little
introduction
um the sister over here came from an
upbringing in judaism so she used to be
jewish she accepted islam so today we're
going to go briefly over a story and
we'll do a live q a inshaallah at the
end
so let's go right in tell us a little
bit about your story your weaver story
to islam
okay
um hi so um i was born jewish basically
um i have two jewish parents so i was
raised quite religious um not only
culturally jewish but also like
religiously jewish i had a different
like different parts of my life like i
was different observance like levels
when i was like born
up to like i was three four i was like
ultra orthodox jewish so you know the
men who wear like
black and white and have the the
palettes and
women wear long skirts so that's kind of
similar to islam in terms of like
modesty and you know strict you know
strict belief um and then after my
parents got divorced um
we like left that community my mom took
us out and we were still religious but
like um less i guess
but i went to like a jewish school still
from like
basically gartery all the way to
um
the end of high school so i had a jewish
education from home
and
from school so i learned about you know
jewish history
jewish like bible jewish traditions
hebrew
my mom is like israeli
she was born in occupied palestine and
uh my whole family basically lives there
um so we don't really have much family
in canada just like my grandmother and
my mom and my siblings
um so yeah i grew up pretty like uh in
the jewish community very much so and
like um also a zionist i would say
because
i went to jewish school like they really
pushed that forward and it's my whole
family you know is like you know went to
the army they super support israel and
stuff like that
so yeah i was
always considered myself jewish even
like
towards like when i was maybe 17
once i was finished high school
uh i started like
even like towards my last year if i
started questioning things about judaism
like why i was doing certain things
um that didn't make sense to me i was
like
i don't know so i kind of started
distancing myself away from that i still
considered myself jewish 100 and i was
like still like proud to be jewish
but i was like i i wasn't as observant
as like i was raised to be and like you
know i was doing it kind of in secret
you know
um being like less observant in secret
because i didn't want my mom to be upset
um
and yeah like i met also people like
once i finished high school like i
wasn't just surrounded by jewish people
so i was like getting other people's
perspectives and questions and i was
like i don't have the answers to these
things
um but then at some point i was like you
know what i want to like get back to
where i was i want to be religious again
i want to have god back into my life i
want to like have this connection with
god because i never felt like i really
did even as a jew and i went to like
prayer when i went to like the the
synagogue and i prayed and especially
like the super high holidays like yom
kippur where it's like kind of like
ramadan you're supposed to fast and ask
like god for forgiveness and for all
your sins and
a lot of praying involved and i just
never felt anything and i always felt
guilty about that
because like i would see the woman next
to me like crying you know and like
asking god for forgiveness and they
really had a connection i just felt
nothing and it was just always forced i
would just pray and fast because like i
had to because my mom like i didn't want
to be a disappointment i didn't want to
be like the one in the family who was
like
not praying and stuff so but it was
never really from my heart
um but i wanted to find that so
once i graduated high school i was like
okay you know what i'm gonna try to find
that on my own
uh maybe if like i learned the religion
on my own it's gonna be more for myself
and i'll i'll feel more connected to it
but ultimately
doing research
about judaism
led me to islam basically and it wasn't
like a quick transition it was like slow
i just had like
for like about a year i would like have
little thoughts about islam and like
learn things about islam but i always
like pushed it aside and it was only
maybe like a year
after you know initially thinking about
islam i was like okay like what happens
if i just say this shahada and become a
muslim so i just took the shahada and
i'm like i'll see what happens from
there and
i was learning more every day since i
learned how to pray
and yeah i read quran and then like
basically here i am today still muslim
i'm the after four years
so that's pretty much my story
savannah so a lot of stuff to unpack
here but the two main questions that i
would have
um before i le and i'll take over is
number one you mentioned occupied
palestine now that's something that you
don't get in the whole typical israeli
nazi um not not just just the the
typical type of zionist um narrative
and you mentioned in a lot of your
videos that you had to unlearn some of
those things so do you want to get into
that
yeah sure so basically um i was always
just like i made like a video explaining
specifically how i unlearned zionism
like i cover everything but basically
the reason i was a zionist was like for
a few reasons because first of all in
judaism the land of israel is mentioned
many times and it is a holy land for
jews um jerusalem is super holy just as
it is for muslims and christians it's
very holy for jews as well so that's
something that until today i obviously
believe it's a holy country
for them it's a holy place for them
um and in the torah um and even at the
quran at some point allah promised you
know the jews the land um
so i was always like but like i rejected
all the stuff that came afterwards when
you know allah like exiled the jews from
the land and everything but i was just
like no but that's we have a connection
to this land so this is why i'm a
zionist because we have a connection to
the land it has a lot to do with judaism
there's like the holy there's a temple
there there was so much history there
they had
so much jewish history there so like to
me that was one reason another reason
was like to me i was like oh but like we
got it fairly right so there was a war
and we conquered it and it was fair we
won the war and that's how wars work if
you beat the person you take the land so
that was like another thing and a third
thing was just like
kind of you're just like the
demonization i guess of palestinians
saying like look they don't want peace
we want peace
we can have peace the problem is the
palestinians if they don't want peace
and like we've offered them you know
deals and lands and this and they don't
want that
so that was kind of like what made me a
zionist i was like it just makes sense
so like i was kind of using like
rationale but like
of like oh we want it fair and square
but i wasn't using like you know like
looking through it like through an
empathetic lens i wasn't being
empathetic about it i wasn't thinking
like hey put yourself in this person's
shoes
um you know imagine you were kicked out
of your home randomly and you had to
flee another six million you know
palestinians who are refugees and not
allowed back in i just never took the
other perspective i always just saw the
israeli perspective because i went to a
jewish school i only basically knew
jewish people
and it was just shoved down my throat
basically so like i would say i was
brainwashed you know in that sense
because it was all i was seeing um and
to unlearn that it was basically
i remember like i already mentioned it
like on some some other channel i think
i was interviewed by a girl named aisha
rosalie and i said like when i started i
basically made up like a twitter like a
fake twitter let's say and i was like
okay that was when i started being
interested in islam so i was like i'm
gonna start like posting stuff like you
know quotes of the quran i didn't want
to post it on my personal account
because you know like
people would be like what are you doing
um so
i started like following a bunch of
muslim accounts and palestinian accounts
and that's when i started finally seeing
the palestinian perspective and that was
the first time where i was like okay
what the palestinian people have their
own side they have their own perspective
they have their own stories and i never
considered that you know but people
palestinians have their own stories like
their own parents or grandparents were
like thrown out of their house or their
house was demolished and stuff like that
and i started reading books i read a
book called palestine speaks and that's
like stories directly from palestinians
talking about their stories of how their
lives are under occupation and that's
when i started realizing like it's not
one side there's two sides and the other
side is the palestinian side is
suffering much more and i just never
thought of it i just never
like i guess i never like considered
them human enough to even look at their
perspective and then once i started
seeing like
the reality of like how it affects
palestinians i always started realizing
that these laws are not just
laws simple laws they really affect
palestinians and they like destroy their
lives
yeah pretty much
subhanallah and my second question was
you mentioned a lot about your
upbringing but in terms of your
reversion to islam what really did it
for you some people they come across a
video that was that just did it for them
other people they read the quran with
intention and they reflect and that did
it for them so what was it for you
well i think for me like um like i said
it was many different things like it
took over time like i would watch videos
about like debates like rabbis and
muslims talking about religion rabbis
muslims rabbis and chefs like talking
about
islam and judaism
to me it was basically like realizing
that it was just one god because this
whole time i was under the impression
i had a lot of misconceptions about
islam so when i realized that muslims
don't worship a different god called
allah
and allah just means god in arabic i was
like okay so they worship the same god
and then when i read the quran i
realized that they said we believe in
the same god as the god of the torah and
the god of the injil it's the same
religion
and that's when i started making sense
to me and also
like why i also realized like why should
i
like
why not believe that the prophet of
muhammad was a prophet like why would it
stop at you know
malacca i think was the last jewish
prophet but the torah doesn't say
malachi is the jewish prophet after that
there's none so why it's so hard to
believe that jesus wasn't a prophet and
and that muhammad um peace be upon him
was a prophet there was just no reason
not to believe it and there was like
proofs in the quran that also helped of
course like scientific evidences and
like
of the quran that you know were
discovered before science discovered
them so just the validity of the quran
was and the fact that there was no
mistakes no contradictions
it was just like i realized it was such
a holy book and a divine book and it
couldn't be written by a human being and
that being said i was like why shouldn't
it be written by god there's nothing
that disproves that so like if there's
no evidence against it and there's so
much evidence for it i was like
logically there's no reason
not to be muslim
pretty much
[Music]
so from there it was just uh like a
straight shot you said oh i'm taking my
shahada and then
pretty much
yeah like it was first there was ramadan
so like i don't consider that
remembering so i had to excited to get
in my room alone and like
it was just out of curiosity because i
was like it was approaching ramadan and
i was like hey what happens like how do
you become muslim i just googled it it
just says the sentence and you're a
muslim so i said it and i'm like now
what
so then
that ramadan i decided to do ramadan and
i was like you know what if i'm going to
do ramadan i want to learn how to pray
and subhanallah i learned how to pray
like i didn't speak arabic at all and i
learned how to pray like relatively
quickly and like i didn't speak arabic
but i memorized all the like you know
the necessary surahs you know
and um
i learned it pretty quickly and i was
like subhanallah then later in january
so that was in the summer and then in
january i like spoke to a girl that i
met online and i was like okay i want to
be muslim like what do i do and she took
me to um
the masjid and that's when i became
officially a muslim i guess
so question question you said that you
didn't have the connection with
allah
and that you were you wanted to
basically seek that
so
do you feel like you found that
connection with allah do you feel like
you're still searching for that
connection
no subhanallah i did find it i find that
when i pray
in islam i feel a much
a bigger connection i don't know like
when i pray like i would never cry
during prayer when i was jewish like
ever ever ever the words were just the
words coming out of my mouth and they
felt meaningless and then subhanallah
like
i don't always cry during prayer but
sometimes i do i just feel very
close to allah
it just feels really amazing honestly
and ramadan it's a blessing and i and i
do it more out of love than out of like
need like the jewish past i do it more
because i need to do it but
in ramadan i feel like i'm excited more
to to fast and to take part in that
yeah i feel that so when was the first
time that like
you know you started crying during your
prayer and you realized that oh damn
this is this is actually real
um i think it was ramadan like when i
was doing sarah that was like the second
ramadan did like when i was officially
muslim i don't know it was just like all
the emotions and uh
i just like reflected on how like
blessed i felt that i that like a lot
like i feel like allah chose me to
become muslim because i was not born
muslim and like he guided me to the
right path and i feel like blessed that
allah saw me and had like mercy on me
and saw that i was looking for something
more and and guided me because without
allah obviously i wouldn't be here today
i wouldn't be muslim it's by the grace
of god that i'm like here today and i am
muslim
um and also i said this like in a tick
tock that i made but basically there was
like one time where like i it really
solidified like like it was after i took
my shahada but it really solidified like
okay yeah 100 i'm muslim it was like
basically i got like a sign i would say
from god people think it's like crazy it
sounds crazy but i remember watching
this video
um of this guy who was like thinking
about converting and he's like if you're
a real god give me a sign give me a sign
um
and then after he opened the quran and
then it like it said like oh you ask for
signs but look around you like a certain
ayah i don't know the perfect ayah but
it's like just like the like
the creation you know that's like a sign
like there's signs all around you
and then after anyways i was like okay i
want to sign too so like i don't know it
was like maybe weeks or months later
and like i was like trying to fall
asleep but i couldn't sleep because like
i had not told my family that i was
muslim and i was thinking about home my
whole life i'm like how am i going to be
muslim like when i have kids and i get
married inshallah like my family's going
to need to know i'm muslim like how is
that going to happen are they going to
like disown me are they going to hate me
anyways i was stressing out i couldn't
sleep and i was just like overthinking
and it was like hours i was trying to
sleep
then i was like okay go to sleep go to
sleep and for some reason in my brain it
was like two two one four two two one
four two and i was like what is this
number in my head sometimes i have like
random thoughts in my brain and i don't
know why and i was like please go away i
want to sleep but then after i'm like
you know what two two and four sounds
like a quite anverse for some reason it
just like went over me so i was like no
you're crazy just go to sleep and then i
was like you know what i'm not gonna
sleep well if i don't check it so i went
online and wrote quran 2214 and
subhanallah it was the verse about like
um
i don't know i can pull it up maybe but
it was a first talking about like the
first muslims when they converted to
islam and they were like you know
worried and like they had a lot of
hardships and and allah says like don't
worry because the help of allah is near
and i was like oh my god subhanallah i
was like i really had shivers like i i
was like my heart stopped for a second
and i had shivers and i was like okay
i'm gonna go sleep now
i just fell asleep super easy it's upon
a lot at that point i was like it could
be a coincidence you know like people
who are like sciento i don't believe in
god it could be a coincidence yeah it
could be
but i don't know to me it was a sign
from god that like god was like saw that
i was struggling and was like
i don't know maybe like i don't know how
it happened because i didn't know the
quran well at all so like i couldn't
have known that that was a verse you
know anyways that was crazy that was
basically one of the things that i was
like okay yeah
i'm muslim
yeah that's not a coincidence
there's nothing really that's a
coincidence in this world's panel though
that's um
[Music]
that's amazing
that's amazing so it actually took you
over a year before you actually
had this connection with allah that's
interesting
yeah
pretty much
so
okay i have a personal question
i have in my family
my sister she's married to uh
a jewish man
you know his family family's jewish he's
jewish
um i don't know how practicing he is
allah knows best
and i'm not here to like
expose anything i'm just
wondering like
if i wanted to
you know give dao if i wanted to you
know like talk to them
like what would be common grounds to
meet them what would be like a good
place to start really
i'm sharing that with them because you
know you were in that position you
were close to people in that position as
well so you kind of know how they think
you know how they
uh react and all this stuff and i'm just
i'm curious i'm curious because i would
love to see them become
muslim so subhanallah something that i
would say like
um one thing that jews really are and i
see this all over like all over tiktok
where they're just like it's not the
same god you worship one god a different
god so the most important thing is to
make them realize that allah like some
people literally don't know this allah
literally means god in arabic it just
means god if you read a christian bible
in arabic or a jewish bible like a torah
in arabic it's going to say allah for
god because allah just means god in
arabic so that's the first thing the
second thing is that there's like this
misconception that like
islam is
america hates jews
just like go over verses that you know
you can search up online like
anti-semitism in the quran people will
bring up verses that like aren't even
anti-semitic or don't make sense or
they're misinterpreted misunderstood go
over those and be like
god is not anti-semitic into anything
like god guided the jews god chose the
bani israel to like follow him to
worship him and even in the torah it
says that they disobey him
when they you know worship the golden
calf so it's just to make them realize
first that it's the same god second of
all it's god did choose the children of
israel but then he just sent new
messengers new prophets because
you know they they started straying away
from the path of allah and you can even
explain to them like one thing that i
always talk about is try to make jewish
people realize that like most of judaism
today is like it's innovation it's not
from god most of the things that jews
practice are from rabbis so be like the
reason why
allah sent you know jesus and then
muhammad is because
they were straying too much away from
their religion
they started following rabbis and
there's even a verse in the quran saying
they take their monks and rabbis
monks and rabbis as god it doesn't mean
that they say that rabbis are gods but
they take their authority just as the
authority of god but you know god has
his authority and he's the only one who
can give that authority so why are jews
why are you following stuff for the
rabbi why are you doing you know
hanukkah why are you doing purim it
doesn't say god never asked you to
follow these these um it helps to know
some holidays
of you know the jewish people and the
origins of these holidays in order to be
like why are you celebrating this it's
not from god and from this maybe you
know slowly slowly that's how it started
for me i started like putting doubts on
why am i doing that beginning i was like
no no it's just because of this
it's because of blah blah blah i was
just excusing it but slowly slowly i
started realizing like okay they're
right like there's it doesn't make sense
to like follow these things that are
from rabbis they're not from god
um so i think it's just to start off by
that to start to make them realize that
muslims only follow you know the word of
god and like the commandments of god and
that's what
jews should be following too and by by
following islam you're actually
being a better jew in my opinion like i
think i'm a better jew than
every other jew who practices judaism
because i'm following god the one in god
the god of judaism the god of the torah
i'm following that god i'm not following
rabbis
so i think that's something that you
really need to make
them realize or your brother-in-law
realize
so these uh rabbis are they
are they making certain practices and
certain things up
on their own accord or are they basing
it off like the torah and all this other
stuff
yeah so like just one example they based
it off the torah like god says okay i
created the world in sixth day and the
seventh day um i seized work and then
it's a sanctify the sabbath day and like
c's work so from that they extrapolated
like so many things like um
turning on light does work because
you're starting a circuit
um
driving that's work because you know
you're you're operating a vehicle
um so from like this commandment in the
torah they extrapolated like 38 uh 39 i
forgot now but it's called the av
so like father of like
of like things that you're not supposed
to do and then from these like like
operating um
of a vehicle so from these would be like
driving a car doing this another thing
would be like let's see like erasing so
you're not allowed erasing so that would
include erasing you know with an eraser
it would include it goes as far as like
you can't cut a cake
on it because when you cut it
you're like erasing the lighting or
whatever you're ripping the writing you
can't rip stuff i should buy you can't
replease you can't rip toilet paper so i
remember when i was jewish before like
this but we like rip the toilet paper
rolls and like so that we wouldn't have
to rip during shabbat
i think it's just like extremely like
extreme basically from a simple verse
that says don't do work on sabbath
they completely like went far and we're
like okay we have to be safe and i don't
think they did it from bad intentions
it's because they wanted to worship god
in the best way and they wanted to
respect god's commandments but they went
too far in my opinion and that's why i
call it biddah because it's like just
complete innovations
yeah see someone would uh hear that and
then they would try to say
you know well something that comes up in
my mind as i will in islam you have the
scholars and you know they make rulings
based off the uh
quran and the sunnah and like before you
know before i accepted the hadith i
would look at this and be like oh but
who are they like they're trying to
say like what the rules are and when
it's like a lot of the one that
decreases but then when you start going
in you start understanding like
their rulings like what they are
decreeing is literally
it's based only on the quran and sunnah
and they're not going into crazy crazy
depths
like what you refer to here which
kind of relates back to uh i think it's
surah
where they um they asked allah they i
think they asked allah they asked the
messenger at the time they were like oh
like
um which
which uh which camera do i get is this
is this another one
[Music]
it's yeah what they um
allah basically tells them to tell the
messenger to tell
his people to
sacrifice or not sacrifice the camel
yeah it sacrificed a camel and it's like
well they asked okay well what kind of
camel and then they asked okay what kind
of color what kind of size like you know
and and all this is it a male is it a
female that's like all these details
and it's like
how much more do you need you know what
i'm saying but bro i think you're
talking about
you know
yeah
no no i think it was a campbell maybe oh
[Music]
yeah
yes
i don't know i'm i'm not really here i
only got a few others asleep but
um to me it just it makes sense like
they were asking for a lot of detail
and then it's like that's how the human
mind works we always want to know like
oh what about this what about this what
about this like as much detail as
possible but then it's like
allah is as simple as possible
you know just like just worship me and
that's it
yeah there's like there's a saying would
you say like being jewish is hard like
that's what jews believe that being a
jew is supposed to be super hard but i
don't think i don't think god wants that
for us god just wants us to believe in
him and and respect him and worship him
and like obey his commandments and
that's why it's so hard to become a jew
you have to convert to become a jew it
takes over a year you need to do a bunch
of different things know in depth which
to me is just ridiculous because that's
not even a based on the torah the torah
never says how to become a jew and you
have to do a year of like studying
um and second of all if you believe in
god and his message why do you need to
like work for a year to in order to
become jewish to become a muslim you
just need to believe in allah and his
prophet and his message and you're
muslim subhanallah that's all you should
need so that's what another problem i
had with judaism is that like
who said you need to do this stuff for a
year to become jewish god never said
that god wants everybody to worship him
it shouldn't be an exclusive club and i
feel like judaism because it started as
a tribal religion
it well even like technically islam
started as a tribal religion because it
was you know the tribe of arabia at the
time um but jews kept it out of that way
like yeah we are a tribe we're an
ethnicity and like we don't want we
don't need everybody joining it's just
like the select for you and if you
really want to join you got to try hard
you know work for a year in order to get
it to become part of us
it sounds like a cult
yeah it's like too exclusive i don't
like it like if you want to
worship god you should be able to
and people get a lot of people who want
to convert to judaism
they get like um discouraged by that so
it's just ridiculous to be able to
you know to be discouraged from
worshiping god because there's so much
hardship that comes with it
so
question uh
jews
judaism
it's not
like is there something that prohibits
like eating a pork
and uh drinking alcohol
alcohol no is not prohibited um but pork
is prohibited it's like more strict than
islam in terms of dietary restrictions
except for alcohol so like there's a lot
of more things that um jews can't eat
can't eat any seafood just like regular
fish with scales
um but they can drink alcohol but it is
discouraged to get drunk you know um in
the tour there's like stories of like
how like you know
it was bad when they got super drunk
you're supposed to drink it's okay it's
fine like when you make a blessing on
shabbat you can drink in judaism but
um
you're not supposed to get drunk but
there's like a holiday
which by the way is not from the torah
once again it's like it's good that's an
innovation there's a tradition that
you're supposed to get drunk the men are
supposed to get drunk drink a lot to be
happy and celebrate which i'm just like
that's crazy like that's not god do you
think god wants you to get drunk like
for a holiday
that's not even in the torah to me
that's like completely insane and
it's frustrating and you know at the
beginning of the quran at the beginning
of the revelation alcohol was
permissible so it makes sense that
judaism permits alcohol right because
it's a linear timeline it was judaism
and christianity than islam so if at the
beginning of islam alcohol the
revelations alcohol was permitted then
it would only make sense that during the
time of revelation of torah that alcohol
was permitted right
so
you know linear timeline but then as
more revelations came down it was like
hey you know no alcohol or all just to
be safe because you're not supposed to
drink when you're drunk you're supposed
to just i mean pray when you're drunk
you're supposed to just like you were
allowed to drink but you might not get
drunk at the beginning of the revelation
and then it's like god was like never
mind like don't drink at all because
as a precautionary measure so yeah jews
are allowed to drink alcohol because the
torah doesn't prohibit it
that's insane
i think most of the jews that i've met
they
eat pork and they eat seafood
yeah i mean and they get drunk
yeah i mean that's the thing also one
thing i realized i mean we love islam is
that i've realized that
muslims are so in general i think
muslims are more practicing or they have
like some things that they wouldn't do
um personally i grew up in jewish school
so most kids wouldn't eat pork but there
was like maybe two kids out of the whole
school who were like i don't care i eat
pork but most kids were like okay pork
is my limit you know they would do a
bunch of hadam things like xenon
whatever but pork is like a no-no um
even like many muslims are like that
which is like a funny similarity but
overall there's a lot of people who who
eat pork that are jews because they
don't believe in judaism but they'll
still call themselves jewish right and
they won't
like convert anything else they'd rather
be an atheist jew than be
like a muslim or a christian like
converting to another religion is crazy
because like i said it's a tribal
religion it's cultural it's like your
tradition so you feel that you're still
jewish even if you don't believe in god
there's so many people who are like yeah
i'm jewish i don't believe in god i'm
atheist but i'm jewish right
um
and they would rather be atheists and or
like you know believe in god but like
disrespect the torah and like disrespect
the commandments and be muslim like
there's a big
i've seen so many christians convert
islam when it comes to jews it's like
much harder to get past your judaism
because it's not just a religion right
it's like
your family your ancestors your tribe
you know
so i think that's why
yeah
so i got one last question for you but
in the meantime all of our members that
are here in the chat write down your
comments inshallah in like five or six
minutes we're gonna start the question q
a session round so write down your
questions inshallah right now and i'll
pin it up as soon as she's done the
question but my question to you the last
one inshallah is at least for me
is how was it telling your family and
like you know who did you tell you don't
need to go into too many details
anything you want to tell us but
how was it and then in terms of living a
double life like where are you right now
so basically um i only told my mom um
obviously i took her out to dinner one
time and i was like
okay i'm muslim
and like she's like oh i knew something
was up i like felt it whatever
but she was really sad more sad and
angry my mom is not the type of person
to like you know like kick someone out
of the house or whatever like even if
like her some people like if their son
is gay or this or that my mom even if
they like you know unalive someone or
something she would probably still keep
me in her house because that's not who
she is so like
you know she kept me um
she was just upset she she didn't like
ex you know like
throw me out of her life but she was
really upset and like it hurt to see
because she was like really sad more
than mad or anything and she said she
felt like she failed me and failed her
religion because like she didn't manage
to keep me a jew so she was just really
upset and she also has very a lot of
misconceptions about islam like about
violence and this and not even though
like torah is more violent technically
more violent um
anti-semitism muslims hate jews
so how do you want to be
and things like that
um i i my siblings i have like four
siblings i think they know
that they do know i don't know about my
older sister but they know just because
they've seen me at some point in a hijab
um
and my mom has probably told them but
they're not doing my things
my family my grandparents my cousins
aunts and uncles they don't know so for
them i'm still living a double life um
which sucks because now
um i'm in like uh jerusalem right now
and
i have like uh my grandfather my mom's
dad who lives not too far
and i just can't visit him because
like they're gonna want to take me out
and i don't feel comfortable you know
going out without a hijab and i don't
feel comfortable
my mom doesn't want me to tell them
she's like do not tell your your
grandparents do not tell them they're
going to have a heart attack and die so
don't tell them there's also a lot of
pressure for that and it's just
upsetting i didn't have i was not able
to have a wedding we just like did a kit
me and my husband
so we got married under the ass of allah
so that's the most important but we
weren't able to have a celebration and
i'm worried like if we have kids i don't
know like if they're gonna know how
they're gonna know
so i'm still living a double life in
nonsense and it's not fun but
i started making tick tocks and i'm
getting more comfortable with being more
open
so inshaallah soon i'll i'll feel more
comfortable to like take the final step
and let my whole family know and be
completely publicly muslim with my name
and faith and everything so my family
will know and yeah inshallah
so what about your dad
um
we
i don't really have a relationship with
my father since i'm like two years old
three years old so it's not a problem at
least that um i don't know how he would
react i think he's still super religious
so it would probably wouldn't be a good
reaction either but it's not a really
problem for me
so you you lost connection with him
after you guys split or not you guys but
your parents sleep yes
yeah after my parents split uh he went
to live his own life and we went to
lavars basically
so yeah i'm not sure what he's up to now
yeah
that's shame you know like if
if you're if you consider yourself a man
of god like you would think that if you
get divorced from your family like you
would take care of them you would still
see them not meet the kids
his father is like a rabbi and i saw a
video of him on youtube he had a video
on youtube and because i i was just
curious like google because my mom said
he was a rabbi so i googled him and then
a video came up
and then after her it was funny because
like my mom was talking about how he
wasn't a good man like how he was like
beating his kids and he wasn't very good
and he was like not honest
and it's funny because he looks he
presents himself as a man of god and
you know he wears everything you know
the whole outfit and talks about the
torah and being kind and being a good
jew and then it's like hypocritical but
i am
that's crazy
and i like i know i know everywhere
you're gonna have hypocritical people
yeah exactly
from what i've seen like in islam like
most muslims they are
you know if if they sin if they're like
not the best muslims they they kind of
acknowledge that you know they have some
shame yeah
yeah yeah yeah some guilt and you can
see it you can see it in their eyes
but it's like you see people like other
face and they're just like they cover it
up big time
yeah i've seen that a lot yeah
especially in like super religious
communities where everything is uh hit
kept secret and hidden there's like a
lot of bad things that go on behind
closed doors a lot of hypocrisy
[Music]
it's like that one picture where it
shows
these two dudes
and they're like on this like iceberg
and one of them it shows like a little
piece like that and then it points to
little pieces like uh i guess the good
deeds
or something like that and then the
other one um it's showing like the good
deeds like a lot
oh yeah
yeah you know what i'm talking about
i'm butchering it for sure but
it's basically like the sins the sins
were like
the guy who's like trying to tell them
like look this guy's a bad guy he's the
one that has like the most he's like
covering it up yeah yeah under
undercover
so the first question we have is from
sister sam uh she writes if you try to
introduce islam to your parents or maybe
like your mom and your siblings
no unfortunately not i do it like um
subhanallah i was able to like
get
i spoke there's one jewish girl on like
tiktak who i met at the beginning she
was really hostile towards me um and
like you know the palestinian cause but
subhan allah she somehow ended up
accepting islam like last week so i was
really proud of her so that gave me like
a really um like it made me realize as
possible so like because i was like
that's impossible so i'm gonna inshallah
start try to implement that with my
family inshallah um but it's gonna take
some time because i don't want them to
think i'm like extremist or like you
know anything
um
next uh
question we have i feel for your sister
i'm in the same situation but with
christian family they try to slip
pork in food at family dinner so i
pretend i'm vegetarian
oh that's really horrible
that's tough
yeah alhamdulillah i mean at least like
jews i mean kosher we eat kosher at my
house my mom makes kosher food so it's
halal so i don't have that problem
all right guys if you have any more last
minute questions inshaallah ask them we
are going to wrap up the stream in about
tannish minutes do you have any
questions for us
um no not so much i mean i saw some of
your videos i like your videos it's very
important work that you do so it's very
inspiring and it shall like and help
other people also who are you know
thinking about islam you know
guide them
i mean where can people find you
um on my tick tock i have but i keep
getting blocked on there so i don't know
i i might quit soon um it's
just the written the same way that my
name here is written on the screen and
it's the same thing for my instagram
it's
a-l-h-m-m-d-d it's
for alhamdulillah people say like
i'm like
[Music]
yeah i got a question while the people
get the chat ready so inshallah tell us
a little bit about your journey with
hijab you know was it an easy transition
was it a difficult transition
so like i think i was only a hijabi like
maybe
i started practicing surprising muslim
but i wasn't covering my hair
because i was scared from my family and
my mom basically told me i don't ever
want to see you wearing a head up like
ever
and she has seen me in the hijab and it
was really awkward and she was really
pissed at me and she like never wear
that around me ever and even terms when
i cover my hair like at home just
because like i shower and i want to dry
my hair my mom like freaks out i told
you not to wear that in my house why are
you wearing that i'm like um i'm just
drying my hair
um but yeah so my mom is not really
happy with it and i still get like panic
attacks when i leave the house um
usually in the summer because i can't
cover my my hair i'm scared that
neighbor will see me and like talk to
talk to my mom about it then my mom will
be mad at me because she'll be
embarrassed but i'm dylan this summer
i'm in philistine so
i can wear it freely and i'm super happy
that i can wear it i feel much happier
wearing my hijab um
but i feel really scared you know like
wearing it around my neighborhood
because
there's a lot of people that know my
family there and like
ford's friends and i live right next to
the hasidic community in my
in my neighborhood um in my city so
so like i know that they all know me
like they'll know us as the family who
was hasidic and left the community so
they already have like a bad image about
us so if they see me like
in hijab i think they would freak out
and they would recognize me even the
ones i don't know they somehow know me
and my family so like i never feel safe
basically so in the winter i always wear
my hood over
and i'm careful and in the summer i try
to like
you know
figure ways out to be like less obvious
all right next question
uh where is it on me also to the sister
i don't know if you know but we're the
three muslims right so our third one
brother rami he's a little under the
weather he's a little sick so guys keep
him in your duas inshallah so he can
bounce back uh next question we have as
a muslim is it safe for me and should i
visit
what do you think
um
yeah you can sure um like the pens like
if you have an american or a canadian
passport it's really it's usually not
hard like going there is not hard at all
usually it's some coming back that's
hard because the israeli security tags
usually i don't have problems because on
my id it says i'm jewish in my system
but
i usually wear like a turban but this is
the first time last time when i went
back i wore like a hijab full-on
and they like freaked out and like they
started asking me a bunch of questions
and i was like two hours and questioning
they checked my boots they're like
like there's nothing in there because
there was a rocks in there because i had
like boots that had holes in them and
rocks would enter and they started
freaking out they put it through the
machine
they asked me a bunch of questions why i
converted to islam because they saw me i
should have been like whosoever muslim
but anyways um it was just really
uncomfortable for me
and i think it was especially hard for
me because it says i'm jewish and now
i'm muslim so i think they like thought
that i was like radicalized you know and
like somehow a terrorist because that's
the idea they have you know if a jewish
girl becomes muslim it's because she met
an arab guy who like
basically forced her and there's many
organizations in israel i know too for
sure where they like their goal is to
like separate jewish women married to
arabs and muslims because you know
they're like oh poor women they're like
trapped in force to be muslim and cover
themselves so that's the idea they have
so i think if you're just muslim they
might ask you questions what are you
doing blah blah blah but i think you
still still should go a lot of times go
um many many muslims ago so you should
still do it you might be questioned
longer than you would usually but
i think you'll be fine
hmm inshallah so first question
i got a question
um
the the nikkav
was that your choice or is that
something that you do to kind of like
cover yourself from like just
the mainstream but also like your family
like knowing and all that
it's just something i wear online i
don't wear it in person maybe one day i
will wear it in real life but i wear to
hide my inshallah but i wear to hide my
identity mostly because i don't want
people from my high school recognizing
me and like talking about me and
whatever everyone so
okay so don't you don't have to tell us
your your real name but did you change
your name after becoming muslim
no i get this question a lot but no my
name is nothing like haram um
and i've said this a bit of like videos
about this but you know like for example
there's some people like named amira
that's not a muslim name that's not more
muslim than my name it's just arabic and
for that reason i don't think i need to
change my name
my name is not christina or something
like christ or something like
my name is is like similar to another
arab name it actually could sound error
people just assume it's an arab name so
i don't change my name and i don't think
i ever will because i like my name it's
part of my identity so inshallah
alaikum sister how is ramadan so far
it's great i'm in full scene like i said
so it's really nice it's nice to have
like the advan like you hear it and
everything
um and being with my husband's family we
eat together we go to taraweeh and it's
nice
did you learn arabic
yeah
in arabic i'm not really great i took a
year of like arabic at school at
university so
then after i learned um
like um palestinian dialect with my
husband and his family i don't speak it
very well but speaking hebrew hopes
because it's very similar and that the
grammar syntax sound
is very similar so
yeah i mean i speak it but not very
great
some jews believe in heaven and hell and
some didn't how did your belief change
when you became muslim
well the torah doesn't have anything
about hebrew and hell and everything
about heaven and hell is like from
rabbis and commentaries and there's like
this concept of gehennom which is
jahannam
um and there's like the olam haba which
is the next world
but there's no really description in the
torah so we don't really know as jews
and i never really was i was always
unsure about this question as due to
which made me confused because there was
but there wasn't heaven there was but
there wasn't hell like if you do a bunch
of bad things why do you have to worship
god if nothing bad happens if you're a
horrible person
so um becoming a muslim like helped
clarify that for me alhamdulillah so
yeah
okay did y'all know that in christianity
one of the uh
one of the chapters that were taken out
was the chapter completely about the
afterlife oh wow i did not know that's
kinda and and these people still wanna
follow the religion it's crazy like even
the pastors when they go to a school to
learn to become the pastors
they have to learn that
you know their book is basically altered
and you have a complete chapter that's
completely just torn out that doesn't
make sense to me and how do you believe
also one thing about you said about like
your brother-in-law what you should show
him is that jesus how it was hard for me
to believe like to accept that the torah
was corrupted and changed
but
if yeah
please um so like five more minutes i'm
gonna leave
um but basically the the torah was
corrupted and there's proof i'm like i
want to make a video about this soon
insha'allah but basically if you look at
the dead sea scrolls um which were
scrolls found in the dead sea in
hollister um and it actually shows how
much from the torah was changed and the
death three schools was written 2500
years ago about a thousand years after
the revelation of the original torah but
you can see that just from 2500 years
ago to today's tour there's many
differences and if you want to look into
it you can google dead sea scrolls
um passages like online or something and
there's a whole website that transcribes
all of the dead sea schools and it marks
all the differences so it underlines
everything that was in the dead ski
scroll and um isn't there in the torah
today and and then the x's out like
crosses out everything that um
isn't that right today but wasn't in the
teddy's world
something like that so you can like see
that there's like crazy drastic
differences between two thousand five
hundred years ago from the tour from
2500 years ago to detroit today so that
one thing is just a proof like it's
physical proof that the torah has been
changed so that's one thing you should
like um show that your brother and well
if
if he claims that the torah wasn't
changed
so how did you view the atrocities when
you were still a jew
um of what like
yeah in israel i mean everything i just
found like a justification oh it's
because of you know because if we don't
do this they're gonna kill us
pretty much
if we don't have a wall up then they're
gonna come and kill us and like there
are unfortunately like violence on both
sides you know i'm not gonna say that
there's never been like recently there
has been a tax you know sometimes
but
when you understand the full picture of
it you can understand why things happen
and it's not just one side attacking you
know it's not like just palestinians
just you know
killing jews because you know they want
to but it's kind of it's resistance you
know if fighting back against a soldier
is one thing you know what i mean
um
yeah so i kind of understand the full
picture now it's not just like oh
israel's innocent defending itself
because that's really what i believed it
was just over just defending themselves
but i realized that they were actually
the perpetrators in the whole
you know that's the obstacle to peace is
the occupation right
next question how did you meet your
husband
um well i'm gonna make a video about
that maybe sometimes soon inshallah it's
nothing really interesting
um but yeah my husband is like
embarrassed or whatever so
i'm like okay i don't mind i'm really
open but he's like i don't know so we'll
see inshallah um but yeah we met like in
jerusalem and all right growing up in a
jewish household what are the things you
used to hear them say about islam
muslims and prophet muhammad saw islam
well like i said uh muslims hate jews um
they want to kill jews um prophet they
would say bad things about the prophet
that he obviously wasn't a prophet um
just made up and that
you know
muslims are bad they're evil they're
violent they're dirty et cetera bad
things basically um that's that's just
my experience not not to say every to
use islam that way but that was my
experience people get pissed off when i
say that because they're like you can't
save all jesus like this and i'm saying
it's not all jews it's
my childhood and how i do it
so again with based on your experiences
what is the best place to start for
someone looking into islam
the best place to start i think is the
quran reading the quran and um watching
maybe videos about islam you know
and stuff like that
islam yeah reading books about islam too
that's helpful okay inshallah guys we
have two more questions and i'm going to
wrap up this stream insha'allah next
time so secret questions or head over to
our channel links in the description
inshaallah
so the second last question how do you
differentiate between a zionist jew and
other types of jews and do they
interpret the jewish scriptures
differently
well a zionist jew like zionism is not
jewish to me it's not judaism and it's
not based on religion and i do think
that if someone who's really jewish and
really understands the torah and
believes in god would not be a zionist
um people who are zionist jews usually
they're
most of the time they're secular so most
zionists like their most israelis are
secular
and they support their country but they
don't eat they they get tattoos they eat
poor no i don't think you pork that's
something they don't do but they get
tattoos which is not allowed um and they
eat seafood which is not allowed they
do not go out drink dress
inappropriately like that's most of
israeli society yet they are zionists
because i don't believe they really
understand judaism because if they did
then they wouldn't be scientists
in my opinion
okay
i think yeah you cut it off man
it was a pleasure having you
it's a pleasure being here thank you so
much yeah no worries inshallah is your
uh your story can inspire a lot of uh
young men and women out here and uh shed
light on the truth about islam inshallah
so with that being said guys if you made
it as far smash that like button again
get this video to like 500 likes and
until next time